The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
OK, let's start.
So let's go back to
our starting point
for the past couple of weeks.
The square lattice, let's
say, where each side
we assign a binary variable
sigma, which is minus 1.
And a weight that tends
to make subsequent nearest
neighbors [? things ?] to
be parallel to each other.
So into the plus k,
they are parallel.
Penalized into the minus k
if they are anti-parallel.
And of course, over all
pairs of nearest neighbors.
And the partition function that
is obtained by summing over 2
to the n configurations.
Let's make this up
to give us a function
of the rate of this
coupling, which
is some energy provided
by temperature.
And we expect this-- at least,
in two and higher dimensions--
to capture a phase transition.
And the way that we have
been proceeding with this
to derive this factor as
the hyperbolic cosine of k.
1 plus r variable t, which is
the hyperbolic [? sine ?] of k.
Sigma i, sigma j.
And then this becomes
a cos k to the number
of bonds, which is 2n
on the square lattice.
And then expanding
these factors,
we saw that we could get
things that are either
1 from each bond
or a factor that
was something like
t sigma sigma.
And then summing over
the two values of sigma
would give us 0 unless we
added another factor of sigma
through another bond.
And going forth, we had to
draw these kinds of diagrams
where at each site, I have an
even number of 1's selected.
Then summing over the sigmas
would give me a factor of 2
to the n.
And so then I have a sum over a
whole bunch of configurations.
[? There are ?]
[? certainly ?] one.
There are configurations
that are composed
of one way of drawing
an object on the lattice
such as this one,
or objects that
correspond to doing two of
these loops, and so forth.
So that's the expression
for the partition function.
And what we are
really interested
is the log of the partition
function, which gives us
the free energy in terms
of thermodynamic quantities
that potentially will tell
us about phase transition.
So here we will get
a log 2 to the n.
Well actually, you want
to divide everything by n
so that we get the
intensive part.
So here we get log 2
hyperbolic cosine squared of k.
And then I have to take the
log of this expression that
includes things
that are one loop,
disjointed loop, et cetera.
And we've seen that
the particular loop
I can slide all over the place--
so if you have a factor of n--
whereas things that
are multiple loops
have factors of n
squared, et cetera,
which are incompatible
with this.
So it was very tempting for
us to do the usual thing
and say that the
log of a sum that
includes these multiple
occurrences of the loops
is the same thing as sum
over the configurations
that involve a single loop.
And then we have to sum over
all shapes of these loops.
And each loop will
get a factor of t
per the number of bonds
that are occurring in that.
Of course, what we said was
that this equality does not
hold because if I
exponentiate this term,
I will generate things where
the different loops will
coincide with each
other, and therefore
create types of terms that are
not created in the original sum
that we had over there.
So this sum over phantom
loops neglected the condition
that these loops, in some sense,
have some material to them
and don't want to
intersect with each other.
Nonetheless, it was
useful, and we followed up
this calculation.
So that's repeat what the result
of this incorrect calculation
is.
So we have log of 2 hyperbolic
cosine squared k, 1 over n.
Then we said the
particular way to organize
the sum over the
loops is to sum over
there the length of the loop.
So I sum over the
length of the loop
and count the number of
loops that have length l.
All of them will be
giving me a contribution
that is t to the l.
So then I said, well,
let's, for example,
pick a particular
point on the lattice.
Let's call it r.
And I count the number of
ways that I can start at r,
do a walk of l steps,
and end at r again.
We saw that for
these phantom loops,
this w had a very
nice structure.
It was simply what
was telling me
about one step raised to the l.
This was the Markovian property.
There was, of course,
an important thing here
which said that I could have
set the origin of this loop
at any point along the loop.
So there is an over-counting
by a factor of l
because the same loop
would have been constructed
with different points
indicated as the origin.
And actually, I can go the loop
clockwise or anti-clockwise,
so there was a factor of 2
because of this degeneracy
of going clockwise or
anti-clockwise when
I perform a walk.
And then over here, there's
also an implicit sum
over this starting
point and endpoint.
If I always start and
end at the origin,
then I will get rid
of the factor of n.
But it is useful to
explicitly include
this sum over r because
then you can explicitly
see that sum over
r of this object
is the trace of that matrix.
And I can actually
[INAUDIBLE] the order,
the trace, and the
summation over l.
And when that happens, I get
log 2 cos squared k exactly
as before.
And then I have 1 over n.
I have sum over r replaced
by the trace operation.
And then sum over l-- t, T
raised to the l divided by
l-- is the expansion for
minus log of 1 minus t T.
And there's the
factor of 2 over there
that I have to put over here.
So note that this
plus became minus
because of the expansion
for log of 1 minus
x is minus x minus
x squared over 2
minus x cubed over 3, et cetera.
And the final step
that we did was
to note that the trace I
can calculate in any basis.
And in particular, this
matrix t is diagonalized
by going to Fourier
representation.
In the Fourier representation,
the trace operation
becomes sum over all q values.
Sum over all q values,
I go to the continuum
and write as n integral
over q, so the n's cancel.
I will get 2 integration over q.
These are essentially each
one of them, qz and qz,
in the interval.
Let's say 0 to 2 pi or minus
pi to 2 pi, doesn't matter.
Interval of size of 2pi.
So that's the trace operation.
Log of 1 minus t.
Then the matrix that represents
walking along the lattice
represented in Fourier.
And so basically at
the particular site,
we can step to the
right or to the left.
So that's e to the i qx, e to
the minus i qx, e to the i qy,
e to the minus i qy.
Adding all of those up,
you get 2 cosine of qz
plus cosine of qy.
So that was our expression.
And then we realized,
interestingly,
that whereas this final
expression certainly
was not the Ising partition
function that we were after,
that it was, in
fact, the partition
function of a Gaussian
model where at each site
I had a variable
whose variance was 1,
and then I had this
kind of coupling
rather than with
the sigma variable,
with these Gaussian
variables that
will go from minus to infinity.
But then we said, OK, we
can do better than that.
And we said that log
z over n actually
does equal a very similar sum.
It is log 2 hyperbolic
cosine squared k,
and then I have 1 over n.
Sum over all kinds
of loops where
I have a similar diagram that
I draw, but I put a star.
And this star
implied two things--
that just like before, I draw
all kinds of individual loops,
but I make sure
that my loops never
have a step that goes
forward and backward.
So there was no U-turn.
And importantly, there
was a factor of minus 1
to the number of times that
the walk crossed itself.
And we showed that
when we incorporate
both of these conditions,
the can indeed
exponentiate this expression and
get exactly the same diagrams
as we had on the
first line, all coming
with the correct
weights, and none
of the diagrams that had
multiple occurrences of a bond
would occur.
So then the question
was, how do you
calculate this
given that we have
this dependence on the number
of crossings, which offhand may
look as if it is something
that requires memory?
And then we saw that, indeed,
just like the previous case,
we could write the
result as a sum over
walks that have a
particular length l.
Right here, we have the
factor of t to the l.
Those walks could start and
end at the particular point r.
But we also specified
the direction mu
along which you started.
So previously I only
specified the origin.
Now I have to specify the
starting point as well
as the direction.
I have to end at the same point
and along the same direction
to complete the loop.
And these were accomplished by
having these factors of walks
that are length l.
So to do that, we can certainly
incorporate this condition
of no U-turn in the description
of the steps that I take.
So for each step, I
know where I came from.
I just make sure I don't
step back, so that's easy.
And we found that this
minus 1 to the power of nc
can be incorporated
through a factor of e
to the i sum over the changes of
the orientation of the walker--
as I step through the lattice--
provided that I included also
an additional factor of minus.
So that factor of minus I
could actually put out front.
It's an important factor.
And then there's
the over-counting,
but as before, the walk can go
in either one of two directions
and can have l starting points.
OK, so now we can
proceed just as before.
log 2 hyperbolic
cosine squared k,
and then we have
a sum over l here,
which we can, again, represent
as the log of 1 minus
t-- this 4 by 4 matrix t star.
Going through the log
operation will change this sign
from minus to plus.
I have the 1 over 2n as before.
And I have to sum over r and
mu, which are the elements that
characterize this
4n by 4n matrix.
So this amounts to doing
the trace log operation.
And then taking advantage of
the fact that, just as before,
Fourier transforms can
at least partially block
diagonalize this
4n by 4n matrix.
I go to that basis,
and the trace
becomes an integral over q.
And then I would have to do
the trace of a log of a 4
by 4 matrix.
And for that, I use the
identity that a trace
of log of any matrix is
the log of the determinant
of that same matrix.
And so the thing that
I have to integrate
is the log of the
determinant of a 4
by 4 matrix that
captures these steps
that I take on the
square lattice.
And we saw that,
for example, going
in the horizontal direction
would give me a factor of t
e to the minus i qx.
Going in the vertical
direction-- up-- y qy.
Going in the horizontal
direction-- down.
These are the diagonal elements.
And then there were
off-diagonal elements,
so the next turn here was
to go and then bend upward.
So that gave me in addition
to e to the minus i qx,
which is the same
forward step here.
A factor of, let's
call it omega so I
don't have to write
it all over the place.
Omega is e to the pi pi over 4.
And the next one was a U-turn.
The next one was minus t
e minus i qx omega star.
And we could fill out similarly
all of the other places
in this 4 by 4 matrix.
And then the whole problem comes
down to having to evaluate a 4
by 4 determinant,
which you can do
by hand with a couple of sheets
of paper to do your algebra.
And I wrote for you
the final answer,
is 1/2 2 integrals
from minus pi 2 pi
over qx and qy divided
by 2 pi squared.
And then the result of
this, which is log of 1
plus t squared squared minus 2t
1 minus t squared cosine of qx
plus cosine of qy.
This was the expression
for the partition function.
OK, so this is where
we ended up last time.
Now the question is we
have here on the board
two expressions, the project
one and the incorrect one--
the Gaussian model and the
2-dimensionalizing one.
They look surprisingly
similar, and that
should start to worry us
potentially because we expect
that many when we
have some functional
form, that functional
form carries
within it certain singularities.
And you say, well, these
two functions, both of them
are a double integral
of log of something
minus something
cosine plus cosine.
So after all of
this work, did we
end up with an expression
that has the same singular
behavior as the Gaussian model?
OK, so let's go and look
at things more carefully.
So in both cases, what I need
to do is to integrate A function
a that appears inside the log.
There is an A for the
Gaussian, and then there
is this object--
let's call it A star--
for the correct solution.
So the thing that I have to
integrate is, of course, q.
So this is a function
of the vector q,
as well as the parameter that
is a function of which I expect
to have a phase
transition, which is t.
Now where could I potentially
get some kind of a singularity?
The only place that I
can get a singularity
is if the argument of the log
goes to 0 because log of 0
is something that's derivatives
of singularities, et cetera.
So you may say, OK, that's
where I should be looking at.
So where is it this
most likely to happen
when I'm integrating over q?
So basically, I'm
integrating over qx and qy
over a [INAUDIBLE]
[? zone ?] that
goes from minus pi to
pi in both directions.
And potentially somewhere in
this I encounter a singularity.
Let's come from the site
of high temperatures
where t is close to 0.
Then I have log
of 1, no problem.
As I go to lower and
lower temperatures,
the t becomes larger.
Then from the 1, I start
to subtract more and more
with these cosines.
And clearly the place
that I'm subtracting
most is right at the
center of q equals to 0.
So let's expand this
in the vicinity of q
goes to 0 in the
vicinity of this place.
And there what I see
is it is 1 minus.
Cosines are approximately
1 minus q squared over 2.
So I have 1 minus
4t, and then I have
plus t qx squared plus qy
squared, which is essentially
the net q squared.
And then I have order of
higher power z, qx and qy.
Fine.
So this part is
positive, no problem.
I see that this
part goes through 0
when I hit tc, which is 1/4.
And this we had already
seen, that basically this
is the place where the
exponentially increasing
number of walks-- as 4
to the number of steps--
overcomes the
exponentially decreasing
fidelity of information carried
through each walk, which
was t to the l.
So 4dt being 1, tc
is of the order 1/4.
We are interested
in the singularities
in the vicinity of
this phase transition,
so we additionally
go and look at what
happens when t approaches
tc, but from this side above,
because clearly if I go to
t that is larger than 1/4,
it doesn't make any sense.
So t has to be less than 1/4.
And so then what I have here is
that I can write this as 4tc,
so this is 4 times tc minus t.
And this to the lowest order
I can replace as tc-- q
squared plus higher orders.
This 4 I can write as 1 over tc.
So the whole thing
I can write as q
squared plus delta t divided by
tc, and there's a factor of 4.
And delta t I have
defined to be tc minus 10.
How close I am to the location
where this singularity takes
places.
So what I'm interested
is not in the whole form
of this function, but
only the singularities
that it expresses.
So I focus on the singular part
of this Gaussian expression.
I don't have to worry
about that term.
So I have minus 1/2.
I have double integral.
The argument of
the log, I expanded
in the vicinity of
the point that I
see a singularity to take place.
And I'll write the answer as q
squared plus 4 delta t over tc.
If I am sufficiently close in
my integration to the origin
so that the expansion
in q is acceptable,
there is an additional
factor of tc.
But if I take a log of
tc, it's just a constant.
I can integrate that out.
It's going to not contribute
to the singular part, just
an additional regular component.
Now if I am in the
vicinity of q equals to 0
where all of the action is,
at this order, the thing
that I'm integrating
has circular symmetry so
that 2-dimensional integration.
I can write whether
or not it's d qx, d qy
as 2 pi q dq divided
by 2 pi squared,
which was the density of state.
And this approximation
of a thing being
isotropic and
circular only holds
when I'm sufficiently
close to the origin,
let's say up to some value
that I will call lambda.
So I will impose
some cut-off here,
lambda, which is
certainly less than one
of the order of pi--
let's say pi over 10.
It doesn't matter what it is.
As we will see,
the singular part,
it ultimately does not
matter what I put for lambda.
But the rest of the integration
that I haven't exclusively
written down from
all of this-- again,
in analogy to what we had seen
before for the Landau-Ginzburg
calculation will
give me something
that is perfectly analytic.
So I have extracted from this
expression the singular part.
OK, now let's do this
integral carefully.
So what do I have?
I have 1 over 2 pi with
minus 1/2, so I have minus 1
over 4 pi.
If I call this whole
object here x-- so x is q
squared plus this
something-- then
we can see that dx is 2 q dq.
So what I have to do is
the integral of dx log x,
which is x log x minus x.
So essentially, let's keep the
2 up there and make this 8 pi.
And then what I have is
x log x minus x itself,
which I can write as log of e.
And then this whole thing has
to be evaluated between the two
limits of integration,
lambda and [INAUDIBLE].
Now you explicitly see
that if I substitute
in this expression for q
the upper part of lambda,
it will give me
something like lambda
squared plus delta
t-- an expandable
and analytical function.
Log of a constant plus delta t
that I can start analytically
expanding.
So anything that I get
from the other cut-off
of the integration is
perfectly analytic.
I don't have to worry about it.
If I'm interested in
the singular part,
I basically need to evaluate
this as it's lower cut-off.
So I evaluate it
at q equals to 0.
Well first off all, I
will get a sign change
because I'm at
the lower cut-off.
I will get from here
4 delta t over tc.
And from here, I will get
log of a bunch of constants.
It doesn't really matter.
4 over e delta t over tc.
What is the leading singularity?
Is delta t log t-- log delta t?
And so again, the
leading singularity
is delta t log of delta t.
There's an overall factor of 1
over pi. [? Doesn't match. ?]
You take two derivatives.
You find that the
heat capacity, let's
say that is proportion
to two derivatives of log
z by delta t squared.
You take one derivative,
it goes like the log.
You take another
derivative of the log,
you find that the singularity
is 1 over delta t.
That corresponds to a
heat capacity divergence
with an exponent
of unity, which is
quite consistent with the
generally Gaussian formula
that we had in d dimensions,
which was 2 minus t over 2.
So that's the Gaussian.
And of course, this
whole theory breaks down
for t that is greater than tc.
Once I go beyond
tc, my expressions
just don't make sense.
I can't integrate a lot
of a negative number.
And we understand why that is.
That's because we are including
all of these loops that
can go over each
other multiple times.
The whole theory
does not make sense.
So we did this one to death.
Will the exact result
be any different?
So let's carry out the
corresponding procedure--
for A star that is a
function of q and t.
And again, singularities
should come from the place
where this is most
likely to go to 0.
You can see it's 1
something minus something.
And clearly when the
q's are close to 0
is when you subtract
most, and you're
likely to become negative.
So let's expand it around 0.
This as q goes to 0 is 1
plus t squared squared.
And then I have minus.
Each one of the cosines
starts at unity,
so I will have 4t
1 minus t squared.
And then from the qx squared
over 2 qy squared over 2,
I will get a plus
t 1 minus t squared
q squared-- qx squared plus
qy squared-- plus order of q
to the fourth.
So the way that we identified
the location of the singular
part before was to focus
on exactly q equals to 0.
And what we find is that
A star at q equals to 0
is essentially this part.
This part I'm going to rewrite
the first end slightly.
1 plus t squared squared
is the same thing
as 1 minus t squared
squared plus 4t squared.
The difference
between the expansion
of each one of
these two terms is
that this has plus 2t squared,
this has minus 2t squared,
which I have added here.
And then minus 4t
1 minus t squared.
And the reason
that I did that is
that you can now see
that this term is twice
this times this when
I take the square.
So the whole thing is the same
thing as 1 minus t squared
minus 2t squared.
So the first thing that gives
us reassurance happens now,
whereas previously for the
Gaussian model 1 minus 4t could
be both positive and
negative, this you can see
is always positive.
So there is no
problem with me not
being able to go from one
side of the phase transition
to another side of
the phase transition.
This expression will
encounter no difficulties.
But there is a special
point when this thing is 0.
So there is a point when 1
minus 2t c plus tc squared
is equal to 0.
The whole thing goes to 0.
And you can figure
out where that is.
tc is 1.
It's a quadratic form.
It has two solutions-- 1
minus plus square root of 2.
A negative solution
is not acceptable.
Minus.
I have to recast this slightly.
Knowing the answer sometimes
makes you go too fast.
tc squared plus 2tc
minus 1 equals to 0.
tc is minus 1 plus or
minus square root of 2.
The minus solution
is not acceptable.
The plus solution would
give me root 2 minus 1.
Just to remind you,
we calculated a value
for the critical point
based on duality.
So let's just recap
that duality argument.
We saw that the series
that we had calculated,
which was an expansion in
high temperatures times k,
reproduced the expansion that
we had for 0 temperature,
including islands of
minus in a sea of plus,
where the contribution of each
bond was going from e to the k
to e to the minus k.
So there was a correspondence
between a dual coupling.
And the actual coupling,
that was like this.
At a critical point,
we said the two of them
have to be the same.
And what we had
calculated based on that,
since the hyperbolic
tang I can write in terms
of the exponentials was that
the value of e to the minus
e to the plus 2kc was, in
fact, square root of 2 plus 1.
And the inverse of this will
be square root of 2 minus 1,
and that's the same as the tang.
That's the same
thing as the things
that we have already written.
So the calculation
that we had done
before-- obtain this
critical temperature based
on this Kramers-Wannier
duality--
gave us a critical point here,
which is precisely the place
that we can identify as the
origin of the singularity
in this expression.
So what did we do next?
The next thing that we did
was having identified up there
where the critical point
was-- which was at 14--
was to expand our
A, the integrand,
inside the log in the
vicinity of that point.
So what I want to do
is similarly expand
a star of q for t that
goes into vicinity of tc.
And what do I have to do?
So what I can do, let's write
it as t is tc plus delta t
and make an expansion
for delta t small.
So I have to make an expansion
or delta t small, first
of all, of this quantity.
So if I make a
small change in t,
I'll have to take a
derivative inside here.
So I have minus 2t minus
2, evaluate it at tc,
times the change in delta t.
So that's the change
of this expression
if I go slightly away from
the point where it is 0.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
T here is [? tangent ?]
of k where we calculated
the [INAUDIBLE] to
[? be as ?] temperature.
PROFESSOR: Now all
of these things
are analytical
functions of each other.
So the k is, in fact, some
unit of energy divided by kt.
So Really, the
temperature is here.
And my t is tang of
the above objects,
so it's tang of j divided by kt.
So the point is
that whenever I look
at the delta in
temperature, I can translate
that delta in temperature to
a delta int times the value
of the derivative at
the location of this,
which is some finite number.
Of basically up
to some constant,
taking derivatives with
respect to temperature,
with respect to k,
with respect to tang k,
with respect to beta.
Evaluate it at the
finite temperature,
which is the location
of the critical point.
They're all the same up to
proportionality constants,
and that's why I wrote
"proportionality" there.
One thing that you
have to make sure--
and I spent actually half an
hour this morning checking--
is that the signs work out fine.
So I didn't want to write
an expression for the heat
capacity that was negative.
So proportionalities
aside, that's
the one thing that
I better have,
is that the sign of the heat
capacity, that is positive.
So that's the expansion of
the term that corresponds to q
equals to 0.
The term that was
proportional to q squared,
look at what we did in
the above expression
for the Gaussian model.
Since it was lower
order, it was already
proportional to q squared.
We evaluated it at
exactly t equals to tc.
So I will put here tc 1
minus tc squared q squared,
and then I will
have high orders.
Now fortunately, we
have a value for tc
that we can substitute in
a couple of places here.
You can see that this is,
in fact, twice tc plus 1,
and tc plus 1 is root 2.
So this is minus 2 root 2.
I square that, and
this whole thing
becomes 8 delta t squared.
This object here, 1
minus tc squared--
you can see if I put the 2 tc
on the other side-- 1 minus tc
squared' is the
same thing as 2 tc.
So I can write the whole thing
here as 2 tc squared q squared.
And the reason I
do that is, like
before, there's
an overall factor
that I can take out
of this parentheses.
And the answer will
be q squared now
plus 4 delta t over tc squared.
It's very similar to
what we had before,
except that when we had q
squared plus 4 delta t over tc,
we have q squared plus 4
delta t over tc squared.
Now this square was very
important for allowing
us to go for both
positive and negative,
but let's see its consequence
on the singularity.
So now log z of the correct
form divided by n-- the singular
part-- and we calculate
it just as before.
First of all, rather than
minus 1/2 I have a plus 1/2.
I have the same integral, which
in the vicinity of the origin
is symmetric, so I will
write it as 2 pi qd
q divided by 4 pi squared.
And then I have log.
I will forget about this
factor for consideration
of singularities 4
delta t over tc squared.
And now again, it is
exactly the same structure
as x dx that I had before.
So it's the same integral.
And what you will find is that I
evaluate it as 1/8 pi integral,
essentially q squared plus
4 delta t over tc squared,
log of q squared plus 4
delta t over tc squared
over e evaluated
between 0 and lambda.
And the only singularity
comes from the evaluation
that we have at the origin.
And so that I will
get a factor of minus.
So I will get 1/8 pi.
Actually then, I
substitute this factor.
The 4 and the 8 will give me 2.
And then I evaluate the
log of delta t squared,
so that's another factor of 2.
So actually, only one
factor of pi survives.
I will have delta t over tc
squared log of, let's say,
absolute value of
delta t over tc.
So the only thing that
changed was that whereas I
had the linear term sitting
in front of the log, now
have a quadratic term.
But now when I take two
derivatives, and now
we are sure that taking
derivatives does not really
matter whether I'm doing it with
respect to temperature or delta
t or any other variable.
You can see that
the leading behavior
will come taking two
derivatives out here
and will be
proportional to the log.
So I will get minus 1 over
pi log of delta t over tc.
So that if I were to plug the
heat capacity of the system,
as a function of, let's
say, this parameter t--
which is also something that
stands for temperature-- but t
goes between, say, 0 and 1.
It's a hyperbolic tangent.
There's a location which is this
tc, which is root 2 minus 1.
And the singular part
of the heat capacity--
there will be some other
part of the heat capacity
that is regular-- but
the singular part we see
has a [INAUDIBLE] divergence.
And furthermore, you can
see that the amplitudes-- so
essentially this
goes approaching
from different sides of the
transition, A plus or A minus
log of absolute
value of delta a.
And the ratio of the
amplitudes, which we have also
said is universal,
is equal to 1.
And you had
anticipated that based
on [? duality ?] [INAUDIBLE].
All right, so indeed, there
is a different behavior
between the two models.
The exact solution allows
us to go both above
and below, has this
logarithmic singularity.
And this expression was
first written down-- well,
first published Onsager in 1944.
Even couple of
years before that,
he had written the expression on
boards of various conferences,
saying that this is
the answer, but he
didn't publish the paper.
The way that he did it is based
on the transfer matrix network,
as we said.
Basically, we can
imagine that we
have a lattice that is,
let's say, I parallel
in one direction,
l perpendicular
in the other direction.
And then for the problems
that you had to do,
the transform matrix for
one dimensional model,
we can easy to do it
for a [? ladder ?].
It's a 4 by 4.
For this, it becomes a 2 to
the l by 2 to the l matrix.
And of course, you are
interested in the limit where
l goes to infinity so that
you can come 2-dimensional.
And so he was able to sort
of look at this structure
of this matrix, recognize that
the elements of this matrix
could be represented in
terms of other matrices
that had some
interesting algebra.
And then he arguably
could figure out
what the diagonalization looked
like in general for arbitrary
l, and then calculate
log z in terms
of the log of the
largest eigenvalue.
I guess we have to
multiply by l parallel.
And showed that, indeed,
it corresponds to this
and has this phase transition.
And before this solution,
people were not even sure
that when you sum an expression
such as that for partition
function if you ever get
a singularity because,
again, on the face
of it, it's basically
a sum of exponential functions.
Each one of them is
perfectly analytic,
sums of analytical functions.
It's supposed to be analytical.
The whole key lies in the limit
of taking, say, l to infinity
and n to infinity,
and then you'll
be able to see these
kinds of singularities.
And then again,
some people thought
that the only type
of singularities
that you will be able to
get are the kinds of things
that we saw [INAUDIBLE] point.
So to see a different
type of singularity
with a heat capacity that was
actually divergent and could
explicitly be shown
through mathematics
was quite an
interesting revelation.
So the kind of
relative importance
of that is that
after the war-- you
can see this is all around the
time of World War II-- Casimir
wrote to Pauli saying that I
have been away from thinking
about physics the past few years
with the war and all of that.
Anything interesting happening
in theoretical physics?
And Pauli responded, well,
not much except that Onsager
solved the
2-dimensionalizing model.
Of course, the solution that
he has is quite obscure.
And I don't think many
people understand that.
Then before, the form that
people refer to was presented
is actually kind of interesting,
because this paper has
something about
crystal statistics,
and then there's the following
paper by a different author--
Bruria Kaufman, 1949--
has this same title
except it goes from
number two or something.
So they were clearly
talking to each other,
but what she was able
to show, Bruria Kaufman,
was that the structure
of these matrices
can be simplified
much further and can
be made to look
like spinners that
are familiar from other
branches of physics.
And so this kind
of 50-page paper
was kind of reduced to
something like a 20-page paper.
And that's the solution that
is reproduced in Wong's book.
Chapter 15 of Wong has
essentially a reproduction
of this.
I was looking at this
because there aren't really
that many women
mathematical physicists,
so I was kind of
looking at her history,
and she's quite
an unusual person.
So it turns out
that for a while,
she was mathematical
assistant to Albert Einstein.
She was first married to one of
the most well known linguists
of the 20th century.
And for a while, they were
both in Israel in a kibbutz
where this important linguist
was acting as a chauffeur
and driving people around.
And then later in life,
she married briefly
Willis Lamb, of Lamb shift.
He turned out the term, 1949.
She had done some calculation
that if Lamb had paid attention
to, he would have
also potentially won
a Nobel Prize for
Mossbauer effect,
but at that time
didn't pay attention
to it so somebody
else got there first.
So very interesting person.
So to my mind, a good
project for somebody
is to write a biography
for this person.
It doesn't seem to exist.
OK, so then both of these are
based on this transfer matrix
method.
The method that
I have given you,
which is the graphical
solution, was first
presented by Kac
and Ward in 1952.
And it is reproduced
in Feynman's book.
So Feynman apparently also
had one of these crucial steps
of the conjecture with
his factor of minus 1
to the power of the
number of crossings,
giving you the correct
factor to do the counting.
Now it turns out that I also
did not prove that statement,
so there is a missing
mathematical link
to make my proof of this
expression complete.
And that was provided by a
mathematician called Sherman,
1960, that essentially
shows very rigorously
that these factors of minus
1 to the number of crossings
will work out and magically
make everything happen.
Now the question to
ask is the following.
We expect things to
be exactly solvable
when they are trivial
in some sense.
Gaussian model is
exactly solvable
because there is no
interaction among the modes.
So why is it that the
2-dimensionalizing model
is solvable?
And one of the keys to
that is a realization
of another way of looking
at the problem that
appeared by Lieb, Mattis,
and Schultz in 1964.
And so basically what
they said is let's
take a look at these
pictures that I
have been drawing
for the graphs.
And so I have graphs
that basically
on a kind of coarse level, they
look something like this maybe.
And what they said was that
if we look at the transfer
matrix-- the one that
Onsager and Bruria
Kaufman were looking at.
And the reason it was
solvable, it looked very much
like you had a
system of fermions.
And then the insight is that
if we look at these pictures,
you can regard this as
a 1-dimensional system
of fermions that is
evolving in time.
And what you are looking at
these borderline histories
of two particles
that are propagating.
Here they annihilate each other.
Another pair gets
created, et cetera.
But in one dimensions, fermions
you can regard two ways--
either they cannot occupy the
same site or you can say, well,
let them occupy in same site,
but then I introduce these
factors of minus 1 for
the exchange of fermions.
So when two fermions cross
each other in one dimension,
their position
has been exchanged
so you have to put a
minus 1 for crossing.
And then when you sum over all
histories for every crossing,
there will be one that
touches and goes away.
And the sum total of
the two of them is 0.
So the point is that
at the end of the day,
this theory is a theory
of three fermions.
So we have not solved,
in fact, an interacting
complicated problem.
It is.
But in the right
perspective, it looks
like a bunch of fermions that
completely non-interacting pass
through each other
as long as we're
willing to put the minus 1 phase
that you have for crossings.
One last aspect to
think about that you
learn from this
fermionic perspective.
Look at this expression.
Why did I say that this
is a Gaussian model?
We saw that we could
get this, z Gaussian,
by doing an integral
essentially over weights
that were continuous by i.
And the weight I could click
here as kij phi i phi j.
Because in principle, if I
only count an interaction once,
let's say I count it twice.
I could put a factor of 1/2
if I allow i and j to be some.
Especially I said the weight
that I have to put here
is something like
phi i squared over 2.
So this essentially you
can see z of the Gaussian
ultimately always
becomes something like z
of the Gaussian is going to
be 1 over the square root
of a determinant of whatever
the quadratic form is up there.
And when you take the log
of the partition function,
the square root of the
determinant becomes minus 1/2
of the log of the
determinant, which
is what we've been calculating.
So that's obvious.
You say this object
over here that you
write as an answer is also
log of some determinant.
So can I think of these as
some kind of a rock that
is prescribed according to
these rules on a lattice,
give weights to jump
according to what I have,
then do a kind of
Gaussian integration
and get the same answer?
Well, the difficulty
is precisely
this 1/2 versus minus
1/2, because when
you do the Gaussian
integration, you
get the determinant
in the denominator.
So is there a trick to get the
determinant in the numerator?
And the answer is
that people who
do have integral formulations
for fermionic systems
rely on coherent
states that involve
anti-commuting variables,
called Grassmann variables.
And the very interesting thing
about Grassmann variables
is that if I do the analog
of the Gaussian integration,
the answer-- rather than
being in the determinant,
in the denominator--
goes into the numerator.
And so one can, in fact,
rewrite this partition function,
sort of working
backward, in terms
of an integration over
Gaussian distributed
Grassmannian variables
on the lattice,
which is also equivalent
to another way of thinking
about fermions.
Let's see.
What else is known
about this model?
So I said that the specific
heat singularity is known,
so we have this
alpha which is 0 log.
Given that the
structure that we have
involves inside the log
something that is like this,
you won't be surprised that if I
think in terms of a correlation
length-- so typically q's
would be an inverse correlation
length, some kind of a q
at which I will be reaching
appropriate saturation for
a delta t-- I will arrive
at a correlation range
that diverge as delta t
to the minus 1.
Again, I can write it
more precisely as b plus b
minus to the minus mu minus.
The ratio of the b's
this is 1, and the mus
are the same and equal to 1.
So the correlation length
diverges with an exponent 1,
and one can [INAUDIBLE]
this exactly.
One can then also calculate
actual correlations
at criticality and show that
that criticality correlations
decay with separation
between the points
that you are looking at
as 1 over r to the 1/4.
So the exponent that we call
mu is 1/4 in 2 dimensions.
Once you have
correlations, you certainly
know that you can calculate
the susceptibility
as an integral of the
correlation function.
And so it's going to be an
integral b 2r over r to the 1/4
that is cut off at the
correlation length.
So that's going to give me c
to the power of 2 minus 1/4,
which is 7/4.
So that's going to diverge as
delta t 2 to the minus gamma.
Gamma is, again, 7/4.
So these things--
correlations-- can
be calculated like
you saw already
for the case of
the Gaussian model
with a appropriate modification.
That is, I have to
look at walks that
don't come back and
close on themselves,
but walks that go from one
point to another point.
So the same types of techniques
that is described here
will allow you to get to
all of these other results.
AUDIENCE: Question?
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do people try to
experiment on the builds
as things that should be
[INAUDIBLE] to the Ising model?
PROFESSOR: There are by now
many experimental realizations
of [INAUDIBLE] Ising model
in which these exponents--
actually, the next
one that I will
tell you have been
confirmed very nicely.
So there are a number of
2-dimensional absorb, systems,
a number of systems of
mixtures in 2 dimensions
that phase separate.
So there's a huge number of
experimental realizations.
At that time, no, because
we're talking about 70 years.
So the last thing
that I want to mention
is, of course, when
you go below tc,
we expect that-- let's
call it temperate--
when I go below temperature,
there will be a magnetization.
That has always been our
signature of symmetry breaking.
And so the question is,
what is the magnetization?
And then this is another
interesting story,
that around 1950s in a
couple of conferences,
at the end of somebody's talk,
Onsager went to the board
and said that he
and Bruria Kaufman
have found this expression for
the magnetization of the system
at low temperature as a
function of temperature
or the coupling constant.
But they never wrote the
solution down until in 1952,
actually CN Yang
published a paper
that has derived this result.
And since this goes to 1
at the critical point-- why
duality [INAUDIBLE]
2k [INAUDIBLE] 2k--
[? dual ?] plus 1.
This vanishes with
an exponent beta,
which is 1/8, which is the
other exponent in this series.
So as I said, there
are many people
who since the '50s and
'60s devoted their life
to looking at various
generalizations, extensions
of the Ising model.
There are many people
who try to solve it
with a finite in 2 dimensions,
a finite magnetic field.
You can't do that.
This magnetization
is obtained only
at the limit of
[INAUDIBLE] going to 0.
And clearly, people
have thought a lot
about doing things in 3
dimensions or higher dimensions
without much success.
So this is basically
the end of the portion
that I had to give with
discrete models and lattices.
And as of next lecture, we
will change our perspective
one more time.
We'll go back to
the continuum and we
will look at n component
models in the low temperature
expansion and see what
happens over there.
Are there any questions?
OK, I will give you
a preview of what
I will be doing in
the next few minutes.
So we have been looking at these
lattice models in the high t
limit where expansion
was graphical,
such as the one that
I have over there.
But the partition
function turned out
to be something of
two constants, as 1
plus something that involves
loops and things that
involve multiple
loops, et cetera.
This was for the Ising model.
It turns out that if I
go from the Ising model
to n component space.
So at each side
of the lattice, I
put something that
has n components
subject to the condition
that it's a unit vector.
And I try to calculate
the partition function
by integrating over all
of these unit vectors
in n dimension of a
weight that is just
a generalization of the Ising,
except that I would have
the dot product of these things.
And I start making appropriate
high temperature expansions
for these models.
I will generate a
very similar series,
except that whenever
I see a loop,
I have to put a
factor of n where
n is the number of components.
And this we already
saw when we were
doing Landau-Ginzburg
expansions.
We saw that the expansions
that we had over here
could be graphically
interpreted as representations
of the various terms that we
had in the Landau-Ginzburg
expansion.
And essentially, this factor
of n is the one difficulty.
You can use the same methods
for numerical expansions
for all n models that are
these n component models.
You can't do anything
exactly with them.
Now the low temperature
expansion for Ising
like models we saw involved
starting with some ground
state-- for example, all up--
and then including excitations
that were islands of
minus in a sea of plus.
And so then there higher
order in this series.
Now for other discrete models,
such as the Potts model,
you can use the same procedure.
And again, you see that
in some of the problems
that you've had to solve.
But this will not work when we
come to these continuous spin
markets, because for
continuous spin models,
the ground state would be when
everybody is pointing in one
direction, but the excitations
on this ground state
are not islands that
are flipped over.
They are these long
wavelength Goldstone modes,
which we described
earlier in class.
So if we want to
make an expansion
to look at the low temperature
[INAUDIBLE] for systems with n
greater than 1, we have to
make an expansion involving
Goldstone modes
and, as we will see,
interactions among
Goldstone modes.
So you can no longer regard
at that appropriate level
of sophistication as the
Goldstone modes maintain
independence from each other.
And very roughly, the main
difference between discrete
and these continuous symmetry
models is captured as follows.
Suppose I have a huge
system that is L by L
and I impose boundary conditions
on one side where all of this
spins in one
direction, and ask what
happens if I impose a different
condition on the other side.
Well, what would happen is you
would have a domain boundary.
And the cost of
that domain boundary
will be proportional to
the area of the boundary
in d dimensions.
So the cost is
proportional to some energy
per bond times L
to the d minus 1.
Whereas if I try to do the same
thing for a continuous spin
system, if I align one side like
this, the other side like this,
but in-between I can gradually
change from one direction
to another direction.
And the cost would
be the gradient,
which is 1 over L
squared times integrated
over the entire system.
So the energy cost
of this excitation
will be some parameter
j, 1 over L-- which
is the shift-- squared-- which
is the [? strain ?] squared--
integrated over
the entire volume,
so it goes L to the d minus 2.
So we can see that these
systems are much softer
than discrete systems.
For discrete systems,
thermal fluctuations
are sufficient to destroy
order at low temperature
as soon as this cost is of the
order of kt, which for large L
can only happen in d
[INAUDIBLE] 1 and lower.
Whereas for these systems, it
happens in d of 2 and lower.
So the lower critical
dimension for these models.
With continuous symmetry,
we already saw it's 2.
For these models, it is 1.
Now we are going to be
interested in this class
of models.
I have told you that
in 2 dimensions,
they should not order.
So presumably, the critical
temperature-- if I continuously
regard it as a
function of dimension,
will go to 0 as a function
of dimension as d minus 2.
So the insight of
Polyakov was that maybe we
can look at the interactions
of these old Goldstone modes
and do a systematic low
temperature expansion that
reaches the phase transition of
a critical point systematically
ind minus 2.
And that's what we will
attempt in the future.